tuesday oprah sold 20.5
of her ownership in the own cable
network to the network's majority owner
discovery
in exchange for 1.34 million shares of
discovery stock
worth about 36.5 million
from own dollars discovery confirm the
deal which will leave winfrey owning
about five percent of the network
she will also remain its ceo and chief
creative officer
the deal values the oprah winfrey
network the channel she
founded before ending her talk show in
at around 180 million dollars winfrey
launched own as a 50 50 partnership with
discovery which put up 100 million
dollars in funding
by 2018 the channel was home to two of
the top five
ad-supported cable dramas among the
sought-after demographic of women aged
25 to 54 green leaf and queen sugar
but the value of own has dropped over
the past three years as viewers cut the
cord and turned to streaming services
earlier this month discovery announced
that it would launch its own streaming
service discovery plus
next year even winfrey herself has moved
into streaming
in 2018 she signed a multi-year
nine-figure deal with apple tv plus
forbes estimates that winfrey is worth
2.6 billion dollars